hi my name is Connor thanks for talking
to us
one of the things that we have read and
talked about in this class is actually
the fact that conservatives are more
likely to give to charity than people
who identify as liberal and particularly
religious conservatives who are probably
the least likely to support your cause
so first have you found that to be an
obstacle in your efforts and secondly if
you see the day when the LGBT community
has equal rights and I hope that you do
what then do you feel is your obligation
to give charitably and participate in
philanthropy I think that the
conservative question my first thought
is it goes back it relates to the
preaching to the choir idea because what
the conservative movement including the
religious right does incredibly well is
they follow instructions and it's what's
one of the advantages that they've had
over the years but it also comes from
the very sort of ideological difference
between liberal and conservative is that
conservatives like order and structure
give us a leader give us our
instructions give us our marching order
we go to church on Sunday you tell us
this is bad we believe you you tell us
to write get out our checkbooks and
write a check we get out our checkbooks
and write our check the more we have one
focused opinion moving forward and we're
all together the more we're going to
accomplish stuff it's good philosophy
very effective spouse if it's philosophy
liberals on the other side or you get
five liberals in a room there are 26
opinions no one even wants to agree
don't tell me what to do i'm a liberal I
fought my whole life for my own
individual unique idea so they're very
the very concept of uniting behind
something is kind of an anaphora to
liberals liberals would all rather stay
at home and do what they want to do
that's what they're fighting for you
know in some ways this is of course is a
humorous exaggeration but not much it's
by definition liberals aren't as good at
following instructions they don't all
show up a church on Sundays they
certainly don't all get out their
checkbooks and write them when you want
them to now but where that is not really
the case
is with the individual groups who are
the ones that don't have rights who are
fighting for their rights when African
Americans are fighting for the rights in
the women's rights movement and now in
the gay and lesbian movement these
movements are very focused these
movements do write checks the gay and
lesbian community raises a huge amount
of money for its own rights and has been
very successful in that in general over
the years so those individual groups in
many ways can compete with the
conservative movement as far as getting
behind something but the problem is that
it's all the rest of the Liberals who
aren't perhaps a member of the group
it's getting their attention it's
preaching it's getting beyond your choir